and II staples college football writers
Sports Illustrated senior college
football writer we're interested in this
Cuyler Murray storing summarized this
story for the audience Andy all right so
what you have is the heir apparent to
Baker Mayfield the guy who is probably
gonna be the starting quarterback at
Oklahoma but he's also a great baseball
player was was a prospect out of high
school but had a great year on the
diamond for Oklahoma it kind of looks
like Ricky Henderson where well he's
really fast he can hit for power he had
a 556 luggage percentage last year had
ten home runs in 51 games so that kind
of you know five-tool type player all of
a sudden he becomes a much bigger
baseball prospect and last night he gets
drafted by the Oakland A's with the
number nine overall pick now that they
have the slotted values in the in great
early draft and the value on that tick
is four point seven six million bucks so
the question now is is Kyler Murray
gonna play football will he be Oklahoma
starting quarterback and he says yes and
they say yes and what it looks like is
the A's are gonna let him be Oklahoma
starting quarterback for a season and
then they expect him to embark upon his
professional baseball career and you can
be a professional in one sport and an
amateur in another kenny hire an agent
does he have an agent
baseball related yeah he can do that for
baseball and and in fact college
baseball players are allowed to have
what they call advisors which are
basically their agents because the best
college baseball players world prospects
coming out of high school were probably
drafted coming out of high school and
had someone advising them on what they
should do when they were deciding
whether they were going to go to college
or sign with a with a major league club
so he's got somebody there and he's gone
just like that remember Russell Wilson
at North Carolina State he got drafted I
believe by the Rangers but he was maybe
a fourth round pick or later something
like that and it was only $200,000 there
but that he lost his job at NC State as
the quarterback
because the coach said I'm gonna bring
in Mike Glennon because he's committed
to football and then
Wilson transferred to Wisconsin Andy
staples back with us as you were saying
Andy yes I heard you talking about Brian
who the ill-fated decision Susan over
Russell Wilson because we baseball
helpful tip always pick the player who's
better at the sport your your coaching
and Russell Wilson was better than
football but no for a caller Murray I
know people asked about the NCAA rules
people always remember Jeremy blue who
was the guy who played receiver at
Colorado and was an Olympic skier and he
wasn't allowed to be a pro skier and
play football in Colorado but that was
because most of the skiing money comes
from endorsements if you're making a
salary from a professional team in one
sport you can still be considered an
amateur by the NCAA and other sports so
you've seen it with Russell Wilson Ricky
Williams split time with the Phillies
organization when you play to Texas it's
it's pretty common and you know it
sounds like the A's are on board their
director scouting said hey work material
to be Oklahoma fans for 12 games which
is amazing to me because you know
they're probably gonna spend close to
five million dollars to sign catch a big
investment and all of a sudden you get
through your five ten hundred ninety
pound maybe you know center fielder of
the future getting chased by 300 pounds
well also I'm looking at this and he's
got two years of eligibility what
happens if he gets beat out for the
starting quarterback you job don't they
have a redshirt freshman who's you know
been pretty impressive here well Murray
came out of camp or came out of spring
practices as the leader in the clubhouse
so I think they would prefer to have
Tyler Moore's starting Oklahoma's
quarterback situation is not as deep as
they'd hoped it'd be
they threw a guy off the team last year
who ironically may wind up starting
against them in their season opener
against Florida Atlantic Lane Kiffin
picked him up girls night out of
Oklahoma Laster so I think that the
Sooners were planning on Tyler murder
being a guy so particularly worried
about him getting be out this year but
okay what I was interested in is the way
the age frame this is that this is a
one-year thing that when the director
scouting says we'll be Oklahoma fast for
12 games and after Oklahoma fenders said
we'd rather it be you know 15 games so
that means we won the national title but
I think it sounds like the A's are
planning on this being a one-year saying
and and him not using that last year
eligibility a football if it's strange
for me because this is the situation
where if you Baker Mayfield six-foot 215
pound guy being the number one pick in
the draft I'd look at 510 195 say listen
there's no way he's ever gonna be a high
enough football drastic to justify
walking away from this or even
considering playing another sport but
what just happened with Baker Mayfield
suggests you know maybe maybe there is a
chance but if you look at the raw
numbers in this thing banded imagine if
the guy becomes a star centerfielder
you're talking eight figure salaries for
10 to 15 years yeah that's really hard
to pass up and they're fully guaranteed
in the majors and they're not fully
guaranteed in the NFL
I just can't adjust for this alkene
taking a five ten hundred ninety pound
guy quarterback unless he is just off
the charts and you talking about a big
ass Baker basically had a historically
great season last year in Oklahoma
the odds of anybody even equaling that
are very slim so I think I would imagine
how that future is in baseball so I'm
not shocked that they're people there
going why is he playing football at all
is he crazy but he loves it and he's
gonna give it a shot Andy good stuff
thanks for joining us enjoy the
offseason we'll talk soon all right
that's Andy staples Sports Illustrated
senior college football writer for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]